الله اكبر الله اكبر
ذات اكاوولين
احضروا العالمي بايجاز من غرفه اخبار
الجزيره اهلا بكم مع دخول حصار بلده حوار
في الضفه يومه السادس وفد اوروبي يزور
البلده ويستمع لشهاده الاهالي مدينا
لانتهاكات التي ارتكبها المستوطنون كما
دعا الوفد الى حمايه المدنيين الفلسطينيين
في حين قمعت قوات الاحتلال بالقوه مسيره
لنشطاء السلام فلسطينيين واجانب لتضامن مع
اهالي البردح في اوكرانيا اعلنت ميليشيا
فاجنر تطبيق مدينه باخموت الاستراتيجيه
ودعت زيلينسكي لسحب قواته منها في حين
قالت الهجوم الذي استهدف برياسكي للروسيه
تم باسلحه النيتو واكدت انه لن يمر دون
عقاب اما كيف اكدت ان صراعات العصابات هي
نتيجه لفقدان السيطره في روسيا الاتحاد
التونسي للشغل يتهم الحكومه باغلاق ابواب
المفاوضات ويتعمد اغراق المؤسسات العموميه
في حين اعلنت جبهات الخلاص الوطني تمسكها
بحق الت بعد رفض السلطات التونسيه السماحه
للجبهه بتنظيم احتجاجات يوم الاحد بدعوه
تامر على البيئه بتزامن مع مساعد السلطات
الامريكيه لحظره دراسه لشركه
تقول ان تطبيق تيك توك بات ينافس نتفليكس
من حيث الوقت الذي يخصصه البالغون
لمتابعته بعد ان تفوق سابقا على يوتيوب
وانستجرام وفيسبوك واشارت الى فشل جهود
هذه المنصات في منافسه التطبيق الصيني الى
اللقاء